spider-man spider-man does whatever a
spider can
hold on a second
that's not spider-man
that's you
what would it take for you to become a
friendly neighborhood spider-man
how could you create a web strong enough
to stop a train
and what kind of spider web device would
you need to invent
you know i'm something of a scientist
myself
this is what if
and here's what would happen if you
could make a spiderweb like spiderman
parker also known as spider-man
developed his arachnid abilities after
being bitten by a radioactive spider
this gave him super human strength and
reflexes
as well as the ability to crawl on walls
but the spidey skill you're most
interested in is the web
that's what allows peter parker to swing
around skyscrapers and tangle up baddies
spiders make their webs from silk a
natural protein fiber they produce this
liquid protein in a cluster of organs in
their abdomen called spinnerets
once ejected the protein forms into
fibers that spiders pull out of their
bodies with their hind legs
so
if you wanted to make your own web
would you need spider organ implants
sorry to say but we're not going to wait
around for you to get bitten by a
radioactive spider
let's come up with our own web slinging
alternative
you might have heard that spider silk is
stronger than steel
and when it comes to physical properties
like tensile strength this would be
technically true but your average spider
web couldn't catch a human or support
you dangling from the empire state
building
there are seven different silk glands in
spiders
they all produce different silk
but no spider has all seven
some spiders produce silks with a lovely
golden sheen
others with a white or bluish hue
but you'd be looking for the toughest
check out the darwin bark spider a one
millimeter thick thread of this silk
could support the weight of a panda
dangling from it
eh tough but not tough enough
switch over to a merging steel cable of
the same thickness
now your web could support the weight of
a full-grown gorilla
but for the heroic acts that you'd need
to accomplish as a friendly neighborhood
spider-man like stopping a train moving
at full speed
you'd need something lightweight and
tougher than steel
like a carbon nanotube rope
at a thickness of two millimeters this
material would have enough tension to
catch a falling car without breaking
though you'd certainly need to hit the
gym and build up your non-superhero
human strength
with that all sorted you'd need to pack
that into spider-man's watch-sized wrist
contraption and you'd be ready to save
the day
well
almost ready
imagine you wanted to make one single
swing from a 10-story building
you'd need 20 meters of carbon nanotube
rope
the volume of rope you'd need for that
one use would be similar to the volume
of one and a half golf balls
and you'd certainly want to swing more
than once
if you tried 50 times per hand you'd
need your wrist containers to be about
10 centimeters in length
hardly inconspicuous but it sure beats
the heavy backpack you'd need to carry
the same amount of steel cable
now you'd need to calibrate the rope's
launch speed
let's start with that 10-story building
your rope would need to launch at a
speed higher than 24 meters per second
to reach that height
and that's about three times slower than
an arrow shot from a bow
you'd get more reach if you stick to
catching villains
launching your rope at a 45 degree angle
onto a thief below would mean your web
could reach a distance of about 60
meters
all this carbon nanotube rope would
allow you to do some pretty incredible
things but
it still wouldn't be as exciting as
spider-man's silk webs
well we're still waiting on science to
work that out
recently researchers used a modified
strand of e coli bacteria to create silk
yeah it behaved like spider silk and was
even a bit stronger
okay maybe while they are working on
that
you could figure out how to make all
this material dissolvable
imagine walking to work and seeing all
the rats raccoons and pigeons trapped in
tons of sticky webs
oops
or worse imagine getting caught in a
giant spider web yourself
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you